[Music]
what kind of forever guys
oh no it's right over left it's right
over here
that was a yeah i learned it at
disneyland
i didn't even know he was cancer the
whole time nobody did
rest in peace the chadwick boseman he
passed after a very private
four-year battle with colon cancer and
crazy how many action films he's showing
i know
during that all during this how does
that make you feel like just
posted on like instagram like a month
ago he was shooting in the forest
yeah it was surprising because i watched
this one show on netflix with kevin hart
you know it's almost kind of like a
behind the scenes series of his life and
chadwick boseman showed up
and then i when i saw him i was like
damn he looks kind of skinny and i'm
like oh i guess he's just like uh
prepping for that maybe that's just how
he is like prepping preparing for a role
that's actually everyone thought
this is what was this what you had seen
yeah yeah yeah he would show up and i'm
like oh [ __ ] but then now i'm like oh
he's battling cancer
yeah i mean one of his co-stars on the
five bloods
he came out and said on an interview as
well he was kind of judging him because
they shot the five bloods
after black panther he was judging him
because he had a massage therapist his
girlfriend was on set
all the time and he was like maybe it
got to his head but then he quickly
realizes now
that that was probably people taking
care of him because he was going through
like chemo and stuff like man people
don't know what people are going through
just try not to judge
i mean i love judging the [ __ ] out of
people but try not don't be like me dude
i like to judge it's fun it is fun but
then sometimes but then
don't say it out loud just tell your
friends well actually
we say it to the public that's our whole
show i know
but the ba yeah to almost shame
someone's body like the weight
yeah you don't know what what part of
the journey they are exactly yeah you
might be like
hey you skinny [ __ ] go eat a sandwich
and it's like i got cancer
and you're like [ __ ] oh [ __ ] or an
eating disorder or anything like that
and you don't know what they were
looked like before and so i mean that's
super
tragic i mean i just watched a bunch of
his movies on saturday when i found out
um or the saturday after i found out but
when people have a funny shape
isn't it funny uh a question
what compelled you to want to like binge
all his movies
i hadn't seen black panther maybe in a
couple years so
i just started off by watching that
again because i did watch it like two or
three times in the theater
and then people started talking about
obviously his other roles and stuff but
i watched this like really
uh random netflix one called uh
something the king
or something but it was like an action
loki movie
and he's just a good actor all around
not just
playing a superhero or he played like a
totally new character his own
rendition of and uh i just kept hearing
about
his respect of acting right that's what
you keep hearing from all his fellow
co-stars
so really watching it now in that
perspective and now
and now to also know that he was also
battling all that stuff
it makes you respect the performance
even more so if y'all
end up watching it i get something again
of his yeah
yeah it's that much better check it out
and it's also rough because like
um i don't know where i heard this but
like like
the public was kind of um
demanding that like michael b jordan
jordan like speak up on it where they
were like
how are you like how do you feel about
this how did like how did this affect
you and stuff
and it's just like damn that kind of
sucks like when you're in the limelight
like
you're it's like you're kind of not
allowed to be human and like grieve
you know what if you just came out and
said shut the [ __ ] up and let me cry
[ __ ]
yeah did say something about like
silence is pain or something
i i saw something like that tell us how
you feel let us get the inside scoop
i mean i'm not gonna even lie like i was
checking all of the avengers co-stars
plus michael b jordan to just read what
they said i think checking is okay but i
think
demanding answers going a step above and
then writing it out and like multiple
people do yeah like are you sad hello
tell us
what do you think no i'm laughing in my
bed right now and i think it's the
greatest news ever like no obviously
like they're human
i think that's what a lot of people
forget yeah that's what i did when uh
when i found out
grant amahara died the one the asian guy
from mythbusters
no way just to check if his certain
co-stars were yeah yeah i went on all
the different instagrams seeing
what they posted and stuff like that
because because yeah i was super
involved with like all the [ __ ] that he
was making so i started checking
everybody's
and then when they didn't post it you
start checking it again you're like oh
did they post something now because it
gives you comfort
for sure if like you're reading other
people are in pain as well
of course so like it's kind of a selfish
thought are you in pain too like me it
really is like a
selfish thing thank god you are yeah i
mean i think that's why it's annoying
it's because it's like i'm not here to
soothe your [ __ ] while i'm in pain right
this is my actual friend
yeah you're you might have somewhat of a
connection as a fan
but it's like you don't [ __ ] know him
shut the [ __ ] up and let us do our
family [ __ ] you know
yeah let us grieve especially because
most of them didn't know yeah they had
cancer it was a very very very well how
close were they
they should have known huh but they were
close enough to selfishly also wondering
like
i wonder if michael b jordan knew and
he's going to say
i knew it all along [ __ ] like that they
made it very clear that
absolutely no one from like that was
involved in black panther knew
it makes sense though because it would
[ __ ] with their minds and it would
they probably probably as an actor was
like i don't want to add that
to my co-stars right and the director
yes
exactly and then also like you know
talking about black
black panther you know how there was
supposed to be a sequel or there is
supposed to be a sequel
they were due to go into production in
march
and so sources are saying that chadwick
was
he was convinced up until a week before
his death that he would
beat cancer he re he was so convinced
that he would be able to gain the weight
back
and he was gonna start preparing for for
filming
this month wow what a [ __ ] beautiful
mindset though to be like
i got this this is like i'm doing it
like it's such a positive state to be
but then you died did do it
he made so many amazing movies in
between though he it wasn't like he was
like oh this thing sucks and he like
you know went into his home and he
didn't do [ __ ] he did everything
yeah that is beautiful i also saw i
forgot who said this but someone was
like he
like he didn't he didn't lose to cancer
he beat it because he still lived his
life he still did it
like he left a legacy exactly like he
made he had purpose
what if the cancer gave him purpose
because he's like i ain't got no [ __ ]
time for your [ __ ] i'm not gonna go
watch movies i'm gonna make a [ __ ]
movie see you in peace
right i mean he yeah he had a an
interview with larry king
i don't know when it was but it was
definitely now putting the timeline
together he had cancer at this time
but uh larry king asked him what's
chadwick in 10 years and he just
his answer was like hopefully i've had
spent time with my family
like that's what his answer was it
wasn't even like
i hope i make black panther two and
three and four
it was literally like that kind of thing
you know what really got me
was there was this one clip where he was
with the black panther cast
and they were being interviewed for
something about the kids with the kids
and then he started
choked up when he was talking about kids
with terminate
terminally ill he's just talking about
the kids but he's really talking about
himself
well he could relate to it you could
relate to them yeah what do you say
oh we're not gonna tell you okay we're
not gonna tell you
she's not gonna do a spoiler it's just
he got choked
up just talking about them like because
they were holding on
to watch black panther like that's what
they were telling chadwick they're like
we want to stay alive enough to be able
to watch
black panther when it comes out so
pretty much like the context of it
like all black kids want i mean all any
a kid want
is to see them as a superhero as yours
themselves right like that's not white
so even for us we don't have our
superheroes asians and so for them
they're like [ __ ]
finally there's gonna be a black
superhero but they have cancer so
they're like i hope that
we can survive this to see this being
made and so for him
he was getting choked up about it
because they ended up not
being able to survive until the movie
came out i'm sorry asian kids
you just have me in the cape right now
well you got semen coming up
ah but it's seamudo you know
i'm just kidding i'm just kidding but it
seemed he just plays basketball yeah
no doesn't is he's he's salty because he
didn't invite him to his basketball game
yeah he didn't invite me to the
basketball game where it came from
but yeah so kids all around started
uh having their own tributes yeah
exactly
what kind of forever man yeah so like
with all those but i look like tim
delegato and [ __ ]
that's an asian kid yes yeah and then so
they are surrounding all of their
their marvel characters around black
panther's action figure and they're just
yeah a tribute watch it's like the
parents who are the actual
enthusiasts and kids don't even know
what the [ __ ] is going on
one of the tweets that i saw was they
were saying like
why does this look like the kids are
kind of forced to pose
that's one two as a parent if this is
really your hero or like
your kid's hero why would you tell them
that they died like they can find out
later
but i mean they're stupid they want to
have like a honest conversation with
their kid i don't know
yeah that's that way they can like daddy
leave with their kid rather than their
kids playing out
like dude with a lot of shock on that
yeah internet is so easy
that's true because i tell isaac
whenever i find out stuff and
yeah it's true he is he is such an
honorable guy like i was like i would be
like i can't wait to tell you if i got
[ __ ] cancer full
right when everyone was trolling him and
stuff for his weight people were like
calling um
crack panther and stuff like nine gag
had this whole meme that said
went from black panther to crack panther
because they had a uh
a picture of him also outside in a robe
and stuff like probably
coming out of the hospital and they
meaned it for a while good
couple months and uh they're getting in
big trouble now
i hope so i mean morally for sure yeah i
mean it is 9 gag though
but it's still sad to know now yeah
so a lot of people are saying like you
know his passing and the fact that he
kept his struggle so private
again going back to what you were saying
it was just like now we have to just be
considerate of everyone's journey and
everyone's struggles like private
struggles that
should have been already why would you
just ask the question hey do you have
cancer
no okay i'mma roast the [ __ ] out of you
right now that's true hey i want to make
fun of you
yeah but can i just gotta guess all the
diseases they might have first
yeah oh okay do you have these and you
ask them like the first five questions
and once they clear the survey then you
can start going
but you're an idiot if you have to ask
if they have obesity
what yes right
we said all right yes unless they're
blind and they're just asking then
you're kind of mean
true oh yeah a blind guy's like yo i'm
about to [ __ ] roast the [ __ ] out of
you dude
like like are you obese cause i don't
want to say
you know yeah i mean but there there
could be different
reasons for that obesity right like yeah
joe
i'm like that's funny that you you
didn't consider both people in this
scenario
their own struggles no no well you're
telling me that a blind friend can't
have a fat friend
like and he's gonna don't flip it on us
you're the bad guy
he's like i want to roast you right now
but i need to know
you know because i think i think i think
uh
the bart's rule is good you know yeah
let's leave it on bart
i think this rule is good we gotta ask
before we do things you know
because um you can't you can't you can't
make fun of people unless you
understand their struggle when you
understand their struggle you can make
fun of them but then does that mean you
have to keep interviewing them to find
out what
maybe why they're obese then and then
why that could have happened maybe he
means you got to be their good friend so
that you know what's going on in their
life
yeah because when you're when you guys
are close you can say whatever the [ __ ]
you want trying to help them here
yeah it depends on the relationship of
course in any situation
you know it's not like we are all
entitled to know why someone is obese or
you know etc yeah that's an interesting
topic too because then
now you have social media and how
everyone's sharing their lives
constantly and then when you don't share
something then
people feel the entitlement of one right
like people
don't like brie larson because she's not
really great in interviews or whatever
and things like like the marvel fan base
doesn't
but like that's on her to keep her
personality
like away from the public if that's what
she feels like that's what she wants to
do she has an influencer she's a [ __ ]
you know actor it's like what the [ __ ]
real movies and
yeah not that the stuff that we do is
not real you know
but it's a different no well our world
is sharing
right so it's different from them
they're performing
like and for us it's like even in our
world too we're entitled to not share
absolutely every single you are as well
you're right yeah yeah but
it's more our territory so like that's
why people ask because of the
interaction right but then for acting
or like musicians or whatever that's to
me
they they haven't even shared [ __ ] so
why are you guys asking it's because
it's the culture of the industry with
pop uh paparazzi constantly trying to
get the gossip i blame
tmz put them on talk shows and stuff it
was happening before tmz for sure
yeah but our our industry if someone
breaks up or whatever we have to explain
that [ __ ]
how many videos how many views your
video is going to be you actually went
viral
makeup video of 2019
no one cares about celebrities though
like the the mainstream celebrities or
they go to another celebrity article
that's like this small they broke up and
that's it yeah
unless they made a youtube video about
it though true oh that's the next thing
don't go on youtube like jada pink's
[Music]
entanglement
[Music]
you